the harley-davidson company is
introducing a brand new bike line of
bikes actually that are geared toward
older riders look that yeah it's the
article it's called Project rushmore and
because they want to let older people
ride motorcycles more comfortably
so the bikes will have wider seats and
more stable handling to accommodate
riders in their 50s and their 60s well
best of all the Harley company asked us
if we would unveil their new bike on our
show which i think is a real honor today
the Harley Davidson Rushmore
[Applause]
that's its top speed right there anyway
and of course was the Rushmore series of
motorcycles from harley-davidson now
let's move on another story this week
the White House announced new measures
aimed at curbing what they say is a
pernicious attempt by some officials
[Applause]
try that again all right this week the
White House announced new measures aimed
at curbing the infant
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what kind of reaction is that there dad
you monsters
[Applause]
like yeah
hey let's see how long those actors can
hold that